bienvenido a diego
bueno
tú tienes un podcast de dementes y las
personas que van
son personas que tú dices que son
personas que se cambiando la forma de
hacer las cosas desde su trinchera
entonces el comportamiento tienen estas
personas
he escuchado dices hoy soy un demente no
sé a qué va que es un rebelde no qué
comportamiento es qué trayectoria han
visto has han tenido a estas personas
desde su experiencia
sí
de a poco que sí que dice just the way
she wants en este vídeo ha hablado
menciona de compra gente que está
saliéndose del camino tradicional
rompiendo las reglas marcando su propio
camino muchas veces los llaman locos
muchas veces la gente los trata como
villanos pero el fin de cuentas están
empujando la raza humana hacia adelante
y al final del día terminan siendo las
que hacen la diferencia al final del
vídeo dice que la gente que está
suficientemente loca para creer que
puede cambiar el mundo son aquellas que
terminan cambiándolo desde ahí nace el
tema de mentes entonces ahora sí
contando tu pregunta de qué es lo que
tienen en común yo cuando empecé hace
dos años el podcast dije voy a agarrar
gente muy distinta hay desde músicos
psicólogos científicos hay empresarios
ahí lo que llamaron influencers hay
poquito de todo y dije bueno todos son
muy distintos todos tienen un recorrido
diferente pero lo que empecé a notar es
una serie de cosas que todos comparten y
es que de entrada no bien permiso
no piden permiso para hacer las cosas de
hecho ya escucharon a varias de las
prácticas anteriores y va por ahí no no
tienen permiso nos esperan en los que
nos esperan a que los escojan a ellos
eligen a sí mismos y más en este mundo
en el que estamos donde no necesitas o
las barreras de entrada que existían
antes de hoy quiero ser un disco y
necesito que una disquera me escoja y de
ahí que me pasen en un canal de
televisión ya no existen entonces lo que
une a todos estos es que ellos se dan la
oportunidad y le apuestan a sus ideas
otra cosa que tienen en común y lo he
empezado a ver cada vez más con la gente
que está teniendo éxito y éxito definido
no como dinero sino éxito definido a
están haciendo lo que quieren hacer
todas esas personas que están así
creen que sus pensamientos se vuelven
realidad es algo que a lo mejor días lo
que raro pues tú ves empresario es súper
práctico tiene está la empresa está la
empresa de la empresa y te dice que
mucho lo que ha logrado es porque él
cree que puede lograrlo pues empieza a
ver un patrón hay también de eso otra
cosa
súper importante es que están haciendo y
eso es de entrada clave no nos están
como hoy tengo esta idea y tengo
estudiado muchos de los que están ahí
hacen y acaban de ver como hill por
ejemplo pues ha hecho bastantes cosas
cuando unos piensan que solamente hace
música no y una de las cosas también más
importantes es que hacen arte
hacen arte y creo que eso es algo que
identifica o que tiene a todos el mismo
nivel si conectando justo con esto que
dices una vez escuché una entrevista
quizás yo soy artista
a qué te refieres con ello
esto es algo que la gente
precisamente me administró en diseño
artista que diga yo soy artista
pero hay una definición que hace ser
going
estudiar con él y es un tipazo este que
él define su definición del arte a la
cual suscribo es que dice el arte no es
una cosa el arte no es no es una pintura
solamente sino el arte es cualquier cosa
que creas con creatividad con pasión y
con la intención de hacer un cambio
entonces el arte se convierte así en
pintar es una escultura pero también
puede ser artista si ya eres contador si
te toca tener atender a clientes
directamente es un arte como lo vas a
atender y si lo tomas como tal
hacer nuevos modelos de negocio se
convierte en un arte ya fin de cuentas
lo que dice el local o que suscribes que
el arte tiene que ver con la intención y
con la comunicación no con la sustancia
no con el objeto y al final del día un
artista es aquel que hace algo personal
con su insight con su creatividad con la
intención de cambiar a quien lo recibe
entonces el arte impacta
a tanto el receptor como el que lo emite
no solamente el que está emitiendo el
mensaje ya que soy artista que padre o
sino de un impacto en las personas
entonces vaya y no el arte se trata de
como humano hacer regalos para otros
humanos que los cambian entonces es por
eso que creo que todos deben de sentirse
artistas y no hacer las cosas por hacer
y ninguno de mis invitados es personas
que dice porque tengo tanto invitados en
el mundo corporativo es a lo que se
conoce como jóvenes que tengo invitados
invitados emprendedores y lo que
caracteriza estos es que no van a hacer
unas nalgadas la oficinas no van a pasar
el día y es que me dijeron que haga esto
si no van a hacer una diferencia y van a
ser regalos y cambien las personas tanto
entre las empresas como por fuera
y otro a ver tú estás ahorita con tu
podcast
escuchamos más esto quiero sacar mi
podcast esta empresa que quiere sacar su
podcast todos quién saca sus potes no sé
hacia dónde va todo esto va a
evolucionar algún punto como dices oye
hay artistas que justamente están
cambiando las formas de las cosas
cambiaron la forma de hacer podcast
hacia dónde vamos en un límite o como
entonces
ay son como dos partes por un lado
parece que te dice a sí que es ser un
libro hace un libro hace un podcast
vídeos empieza a subir cosas estoy de
acuerdo con eso
tiene que dar el permiso de que así
puede subir lo va pero por otro lado
asegurarte en tenerlo que decir hacer lo
correcto o sesión incorrecto que tengas
algo que quieras decir que te llene a ti
que no sea solamente repetir lo que
leíste de la persona anterior o
compartir el court que viste de alguien
y ya soy influencers porque es hasta
este mama horita de que todos queremos
ser influencers
y no se trata de tener seguidores por
tener seguidores sino se trata de que
quiere lograr con esto tienes un
micrófono tienes una voz la van a
escuchar qué quieres hacer con las
personas que escuchen tubos no muchas
veces aquí os vamos a por ser famoso
quiero hacer la diferencia entonces en
el aspecto ese de estar generando
contenido estar haciendo cosas de
entrada es va a todo mundo tiene que
tener o puede tener sus medios
simplemente asegúrense de que quieren
comunicar y que están sea esto es mi
opinión y darle y por el lado del
formato de podcast que dices
en méxico recientemente en spotify
fitur de poder descargar podcasts y a
partir de ahí mucha gente empezó
descubrí el formato quien de aquí sabe
que son los podcasts
y quien no sabe qué son los podcasts
perfecto estamos viendo
pero bueno en un ambiente donde hay pura
gente intelectual si tú les preguntas
que es un podcast uno de cada cinco
personas que sabe decir que es
probablemente uno de cada diez ya
descargo está descargar los podcast
entonces por mientras más gente haga
podcast mejor porque se va a convertir
en un año normal no normal va a haber va
haber más gente que lo consuma y por
ende le vamos a pasar de consumir basura
a consumir contenido relevante
y la segunda cosa que tiene que ver con
esto es que estamos pasando así como
pasamos a la era de los vídeos y que
protección si no tienes un vídeo para tu
empresa no existe si me tapé line o
relevante ha estado pasando al formato
de audio con la integración de
tecnologías como alexa
google que tienen sus temas de
inteligencias artificiales
reconocimiento de voz alguien que te
deum alexa de amazon bueno y ya saben lo
que es un briefing
bueno álex se te da por ejemplo la
oportunidad de que todas las mañanas tú
ligas alex a darme mi noticias de la
mañana y tú te suscribes y tus canales
por ejemplo pues suscribirte y te mandan
se escucha un minuto o tres minutos
cinco minutos de las noticias que tienen
que ver con el tema que escogiste pueden
ser conferencistas pueden ser noticias
pueden ser cosas y eso en eeuu ya
muchísima gente lo hace está lavando los
dientes nos bañan está escuchando
contenido y viene muy fuerte para méxico
y todo latinoamérica entonces va a ser
en los siguientes tres años el formato
no va a dejar existir el vídeo no deja
de existir la las fotografías pero audio
va a cobrar una relevancia
importantísima quien está siempre
manejando y dice oye tengo que marcarle
a alguien y tiene que aunque tenga manos
libres voltear este es contacto y
marcar al rato va a ser bien sencillo y
te va a entender la máquina cuando le
digas marca la y mamá o us mina cita
para cortarme el pelo o hazme lo que sea
o incluso de la nada decir oye tengo
ganas de aprender sobre esto
o google que es tal cosa y te lo va a
contestar mientras estás manejando
cocinando las ante los dientes o que
otra situación no entonces va para allá
creo que es un formato que viene para
quedarse y yo los invitaría a que si
tiene esa cosquillita y quiere empezar a
hacer algo intenten adentrarse al tema
del audio
creo que es un buen momento y apenas va
empezando a bajar bolita en méxico
otra otra que veo digo como es una
conexión que entre de mentes internas
dudas una voz a una persona que no tiene
voz
ep desigual es un foro para para alguien
que no tiene este formato es alguien que
nos pica a dar conferencias normalmente
nuestros speakers son dio se han dado en
una conferencia pero no nos dedican y no
viven de ello hoy esta tendencia que hoy
yo quiero ser conferencista yo crear una
conferencia y estos temas estatal y de
su vigor pero justamente no busca eso no
se busca encontrar esto es como cómo
vamos a hacer para que acaben los buenos
contenidos como las estudio todo esto
creo que más que que hablen los buenos
porque creo que ya somos ya somos los
buenos como dicen por ahí somos y si
somos más los buenos
creo que a los que les tenemos que dar
voz y esto se trata de mente es no es a
la persona buena que dice tengo buenas
intenciones tengo buenas ideas quiero
compartirlas y listo de mente se trata
de darle voz a las personas que están
haciendo a los locos que están haciendo
los locos que están y la gente que está
aquí que ha venido y lo acepten
son las personas que están haciendo
cosas realmente que están en el día a
día tomando decisiones transiciones
sacrificando algunas cosas en el camino
pero que ya están haciendo entonces la
de méndez es un foro para las personas
que están haciendo y
no sé cómo hacerle para darle más voz a
esta nación euro que tienen que darse
voz también ellos son los frecuentes ya
existen los medios y existen en los
lugares
pero lo que sí recalcar es que no se
trata de darle más voz a los buenos ya
somos los buenos el momento de que
seamos más los locos
muy bien
y otra cosa una cosa más
otros dementes no es sobre
que el bueno o que el que hace también
se exprese se trata de la audiencia el
objetivo es que el que está escuchando
en su carro y que está entre es empezar
a este negocio o no sé si salirme a
trabajar o no sé si era pedir un aumento
total que que tome lo que está
escuchando y diga quién es su madre voy
a hacerlo y voy a hacer no voy a decir
que padre estoy inspirado y voy y voy a
postear en facebook es que todo es bien
bonito y la vida es feliz si quiero
motivar la gente no es escuchar apago el
estéreo y me pongo a hacer algo va por
ahí
porque justo también busca que soy no
ser un foro simplemente queremos cuestas
únicas sino bueno yo ahí como hago no la
está motivación no obstante la
motivación que habla de hoy es y qué
bonito me calientan la oreja y estoy
contento sino más bien me dan
herramientas para moverme entonces justo
ahí está la motivación que te sacan
dudas cuando un episodio es exitoso es
cuando la gente en lugar de tener toda
la respuesta se queda con más dudas y se
achica y esto como yo era como lo hace
en mi vida para aplicar esto y
lo que me ha puesto a pensar en eso
entonces eso lo que me falta recalcar la
gente que está aquí arriba y en el
podcast es tendría constantemente está
aprendiendo y cuestionando sé el porqué
de las cosas y de esa manera llegan a
desafiar el estado actual de las
situaciones
y hasta esta contradicción no también
puede ser que
seguramente habrá personas que también
dicho que yo quiero hacer influencia yo
quiero hacer esto y el nuevo tiempo
conectar pero en un tiempo no dejar de
ser tú no ser más como en como tú
explicas esta contradicción de
en el fondo
hay dos formas de verlo y una es quiero
ser relevante o quiero estar en el foco
por estar el foco y si quiero que todos
hablen de mí ahorita puedo pararme bajar
los pantalones y todo mundo hablar de mí
no pero no es algo positivo o puedo
ponerme a hacer un show y bailar y
cantar pero no soy yo y van a salir de
aquí van a decir que pero con este güey
porque está haciendo esto y lo voy a
lograr mi objetivo de que todo mundo
hable de mí
pero creo que cuando la realidad es que
quieres ser relevante ante una audiencia
relevante pues tienes que ser tú
volviendo al tema de hacer tú y él lo
que cuando me preguntan oye cómo le hago
para hacer un podcast y como lado para
hablar y además incluso yo cuando empecé
el podcast si se fijan yo lo bien rápido
no gesticuló está mal y le escuchan el
podcast probablemente han tenido que
regresarle varias veces para que dijo
este güey pero
empecé cuando cuando quise hacerlo el
podcast dije voy a empezar a tomar
cursos de locución no de radio para que
me enseñen y algo que me hizo mucho
ruido es que te enseñan hablar así y
este es el programa número uno de la
radio es decir no así no quiero
sonar es no soy yo y el problema de que
si empieza a sonar así cuando me pare
aquí a hablar como hablo ya chicas no es
este güey cuando nos ha pasado que
escuchan a un cantante que no escuchan
el disco y lo escuchen en persona gente
watson igual eso es lo que tienes que
hacer entonces el peligro de que crees
este personaje para redes y cuando lo
traes a la realidad
interactuar con personas reales hay una
disonancia y es esto no es lo que yo
estoy buscando vuestra la persona que yo
conocí acá es súper súper peligroso
entonces yo tira que seas tú y si
quieres filtrar las partes éticas que
vende la gente se tiene que enterar de
que las cosas por el estilo pero
haciendo cuentas trato de ser lo más
transparente posible y la gente
creo que lo entienden y se puede
identificar así entonces el consejo
sería sé que tú habrá quien le hagas
bien pero para la gente que viene madre
y luego aquí nosotros estado es tan
interesante que además todo el mundo
escucha podcast
de gasto para con abencia si alguna vez
no momento que adoptan así quiere
escuchar audiolibros
si no les eres tonto no simplemente a
veces no tienes el tiempo de sentarse a
leer prefieres estar ocupado en otras
cosas entonces
bueno si nos puedes confesar o sea que
me lo tienes que buscas al final con
todo esto no sea más allá del podcast
qué es lo que te mueve
para mí de forma egoísta
y quiero seguir aprendiendo
el podcast para mí fue un experimento
fue por un lado una excusa para sentarme
con gente que me interesa conocer
no es lo mismo que tú les digas que es
con alguien le diga soy lleva todo esto
yo tomé un café contigo regálame una
hora hay una cantidad infinita de gente
que le pide una hora a cualquier persona
que le quieras pedir consejo entonces
para mí el podcast es una excusa
perfecta porque les digo oye te quiero
invitar a mi programa platicado digamos
antes platicamos durante el programa
practicamos después nos mantenemos en
conversación y en contacto y alargó el
tiempo y entonces vas creando una serie
de relaciones lo que te van enseñando es
increíble las cosas que ha aprendido
estando grabando episodios de las
personas de la forma en que se dirigen a
la gente de la forma en que toman
decisiones y eso en forma egoísta lo que
yo para mí me sirve a mí para poder ser
mejor persona para poder dar una mejor
parte de mí a mi gente a mis
familia y demás
y por el otro lado
este es el mejor me permite alcanzar de
mejor forma a mi propósito que a lo que
he llegado a lo largo del tiempo es que
cuando me siento más vivo y cuando me
siento que estoy siendo más productivo
mejor con terminó ayudando o apoyando
otras personas a que alcancen su
potencial no son muchas las personas que
decimos que yo podría hacer esto pero me
bloquea esto estoy esto o poder hacer
esto tiene una chamba y las empresas con
las que colabore los aspectos que tengo
todos van orientados a que las personas
alcancen por su potencial entonces hacia
donde vaya mente es por ejemplo hacia
allá para seguir llevando ese propósito
entonces me quiero preparar más para
poder apoyar a más personas a que logren
su potencial y así se cambien ellas
también a su entorno directo y así
vayamos cambiando el mundo que seamos
más locos
es una gracia